(beeping)
(uptempo music)
- So, I like to start by
sharing a personal story.
All scientists have I think a memory,
a story that they can go back to
when they think about how they
became interested in science
and I wanted to share mine.
This is mine here.
These are baby leatherback turtles
that are hatching from a nest
not far away from where I was born
and raised in Puerto Rico.
And when I was a child there
I always found fascinating
that these animals
are coming out of the nest
and they haven't been to turtle school
and they know exactly where to go.
They're beelining it towards the ocean.
There's something really
profound happening here also,
very important for the turtle
but invisible to our eyes,
which is that these turtles
are forming a memory.
They're forming a memory of this beach.
These are leatherback turtles,
they grow up to be about
the size of a Volkswagen,
about nine feet long,
and they will travel the world's oceans
and decades later when they have to make
what is perhaps the most important
decision in a turtle's life
which is where it's gonna lay its eggs,
it will remember this beach
because that's where it was born
and he'll come back to and
lays its eggs at that place.
So with that I'd like to
coarse-grain behaviors
and essentially group them into innate
or hardwired behaviors like
these animals' capacity
to know to go towards the
ocean when they're born.
An experiential memory is either capacity
to remember this specific
vision come back to it.
Now, innate behaviors are facilitated
by the developmental program that leads
to the formation of the
neural circuit architectures,
and experiential memories
are facilitated by
a pretty complex interplay between that
architecture that develops
and the environment that
the animal is experiencing,
what the animal is seeing.
But I wanna emphasize that both of them
are ultimately facilitated
by the architecture of the nervous system.
So what do I mean by the
architecture of the nervous system
and this is essentially what I mean.
If you look at a mouse
hippocampus for example
you'll see this incredibly
and exquisite organization
of the neurons.
This is actually image
here using a technique
called Brainbow by Jeff
Lichtman at Harvard.
And this organization raises all sorts
of interesting questions one of them
which my lab is interested on
is how is it that this organization
is actually established?
And in thinking of how this
organization is established,
if you take for example the
case of the human brain,
you have about 80 billion neurons,
that's more neurons in
a healthy human brain
than you have stars in the Milky Way,
and about 100 trillion synapses.
And during development you have
hundreds of millions of
neurons almost simultaneously
during development specifying fate,
growing out axons,
connecting to each other,
finding each other in a
very specific way to lay out
this amazing architecture.
So, how does that happen?
What are the organizing
principles that rules
this organization that ultimately
underpin human behaviors?
Now we look at this
question and we don't do so
in turtles or humans or mice actually,
we do so in a worm.
It's a tiny nematode called
C. elegans, it's over here.
One of the characteristics
that that C. elegans has
that we really like is
that it's transparent.
So it allows us to look
at the organization of the nervous system
which is very finely
organized as you can see here.
Now I wanna acknowledge that C. elegans is
far simpler than a healthy human brain.
So instead of a hundred billion neurons,
C. elegans has exactly 302 neurons
and instead of 100 trillion synapses
C. elegans has approximately
7,000 synapses.
So some of you might be wondering,
how is it that we can extract
any useful information
out of such a simple system
that will tell us anything useful about
a complex organ like the human brain.
And to address this I like
to use a quote by Diderot
that said, "A worm is only a worm.
"But that only means that
the marvelous complexity
"of its organization is hidden from us
"by its extreme smallness."
Now, I'm not as eloquent as Diderot
so I'll say it in a wordier way,
when nature finds a solution to a problem
it recycles that solution
over and over again.
So the fundamental principles that allows
for the proper functioning
of the nervous system
in this tiny worm are not unlike
the fundamental principles
that facilitate the
functioning of our own brains.
And to exemplify that I'll
just give a few examples.
Studies done in this worn by other groups
ranging from the development of neurons
like cell fate specification
or axon guidance
to fundamental physiology, having to do
with biogenesis of neurotransmitters
or neurotransmitter release
or neuron stuck to each other
to even system's levels examination
of sensory perception and behavior,
all done in this nematode
have actually shed light
on important and fundamental
aspects about how
our own brains and brains
in higher metazoans work.
It's really true that evolution
kind of conserves these principles.
So, using that as a foundation
we wanted to essentially
examine this question of
how this nervous system comes together
and both our studies and the
studies that I just mentioned
benefited from the fact that this is also
the only animal for which
we have a wiring diagram.
Now we're hoping this is gonna change soon
and you're gonna hear other talks today
that are working very hard to make this.
You know, I think of the
past now we're very happy
that that's the case
but today this is the only animal
for which we have that wiring diagram.
So, what is the wiring diagram?
It's the ability to know
where each neuron is,
essentially the morphology of the neuronal
and what a neuron is connecting to.
And we use this wiring diagram to examine
two fundamental questions.
One of them is how is it
that the brain of this animal is organized
and the second one is how
does this organization
comes out during development?
Now we've had the wiring
diagram for about 30 years.
The first wiring diagram was done in 1986
and we still have these two questions
that we need to address and
I'll explain what we know
and what we don't know in the next slide.
The way that that wiring
diagram was originally done
was that somebody took,
a group of scientists led by
John White took this animal
and essentially fixed it
and sliced it like a salami.
So imagine that you're slicing
all over the animal here
and then you get these cross sections
and then they did electron microscopy
on those cross sections.
And by segmenting each of the neurons
which we are putting here
in different colors by hand,
this is 1986 they segmented them by hand,
they were able to recreate
the connectivity map
for every single cell.
Now this was this was incredibly
powerful for the field
and it has benefited our studies
but I just wanna emphasize
that all of this was,
it wasn't digitalized.
It was all done by hand.
So you could go narrow by narrow
and you can kind of tell the
shape and who it connected to
but we didn't have a
systems level understanding
about how this happened.
Until recently where Scott Emmons
at Albert Einstein University
and his students Steve Cook
actually went in and did
the same segmentation
that John White did 30 years
ago but with computers.
What that allows us to
do is to be able to know
who's neighboring who
in a quantitative way,
in a way that we can actually analyze.
And we can analyze using
tools not unlike the tools
that are being used by companies
like Twitter or Facebook
to understand interactions
between human beings.
So our collaboration included
computational scientists
Smita and Alex and what they
did is that they took that data
and we worked together with them
in using clustering algorithms.
Again similar to a cluster
in network algorithms
that are used to understand
personal interactions.
And cluster neurons with
similar contact profiles,
so essentially neurons that
are contacting each other
as they're traveling together
in the nervous system in fascicles.
And indeed iterative
clustering to understand
how that structure of
the brain is organized.
And you end up with essentially
a flow diagram like this
where in one corner you
have all the neurons
and this cluster in algorithms iteratively
bring them together.
So, this different
clustering of the different
subgroups of neurons
that eventually cluster
into these larger families,
what it represents, what underlies that
is real biology of how these neurons
are interacting with each other.
Real biology that was inaccessible before
we were able to digitize these programs.
And we're capable of
overlaying that on top
of the original EM micrographs.
Each of these pseudo colors
here that we have placed
represent a community of neurons
that are interacting together
more than the other neurons.
And I'm gonna just walk you
through the brain of the animal
and this is gonna be playing a movie
so that you can see how
the different communities
are actually snaking and how
they relate to each other
and how they come together.
As this movie plays I'll explain that
what I'm showing you here is actually
reproducible across the animals
for which we have connectomes.
So this has been a really fun project
because we were able to
work with the computational biologist
and inform the algorithms with the biology
and use the algorithms to
inform our own biology.
We were able to find four main bundles
that account for 83% of
the whole connectome.
Now we have a pretty good idea about how
these different brain
regions are organized
and these neighborhoods, I'll
just mention that they reveal
important biological insights.
So there's a reason why
they're organized this way
that have to do with
development and function.
I could give a one hour talk about this
so I'm gonna use one
example to present this
and I'll talk about
how these neighborhoods
led to insights about
how this organization
is actually established
during development.
And this gets to a fundamental question
that is a blind spot in the field
which is how do you go from
a group of cells in an embryo
to this organized connectome in the worm?
So this is essentially a question
that we wanted to understand,
and the reason that this
has been a blind spot
is that for many organisms
this part of the
development happens inside,
like for example in mammals
it happens inside the uterus.
So the organisms are
essentially inaccessible.
In C. elegans they lay eggs
so the organism is accessible
but there were a number of challenges
that have prevented in the
past like four or five decades
to image embryonic neurodevelopment.
So this is a pretty large blind spot,
we have this information
but we didn't know
how this was happening.
The reason that imaging neurodevelopment
in C. elegans was
challenging were multifold.
One of them is that embryos,
when they're inside the
egg they're very quick,
they're moving very quickly.
So if you're looking for example
at the development of a single neuron
using even the fastest microscopy
that we had available at the time
which is spinning disk microscopy
for the aficionados in the audience.
This is a single neuron
and you get a motion blur
where it looks like four neurons.
Because the animal is moving
and you're taking different pictures
so it looked at you
taking four neurons there.
The other problem that is
hard to capture in an image
is the animals just die.
So when you're imaging for
prolonged periods of time
which is what you want to
do to be able to capture
these different neural
developmental events,
many of the embryos just die
so you end up taking snapshots
at different points in development
that you have to stitch together later.
And neurons are actually pretty thin.
They're near the
diffraction limit of light.
They're traveling in ways
that are not convenient for imaging.
They're not traveling in planes,
they don't care about our imaging needs.
They're actually snaking in
through the whole nervous system
so we needed methods that allow us to have
good resolution not just in two dimensions
but in all three dimensions.
So to address this we
establish a collaboration
with a fabulous microscopist Hari Shroff
and his team of scientists.
And Hari essentially, we had
these discussions together
and he came up with the
design of this microscope.
I won't go into the nuts and bolts
about how these microscopes work.
But what I will tell you is
the aspects of this
microscope that makes it
usable for our studies.
This microscope is called
a light sheet microscope
which essentially means that instead of
imaging a single point of light
like many other microscopes do,
it creates a whole sheet of light
so it's much faster
than regular microscopes
because it's like in Star
Trek when they scan you
versus scanning you point by point.
So it's faster.
Because it's faster it exposes
the animal to less light,
so less photo toxicity,
also the way that light is generated
to be able to image these animals
exposes the animals to less light.
And the other aspect of this is that
for the microscopists in the audience,
so people who have done
microscopy they will recognize
that when you take a
three-dimensional image
of an object in a microscope,
the resolution in X, Y
is always really good
but when you turn it the
resolution you see it's always bad.
And that has to do with
just the physics of light
which I'm not gonna go into
but I will say that X, Y and Z
is relative to how you're standing.
So you guys right now are in my Z
but if I was standing this
way that will be my Z.
So if I had two images where the Z varied
then I could combine them to essentially
have an isotropic image.
So if I look at this object like this,
this is my X, Y and then
I look at it this way
and this is my X, Y and I
combine those two images,
it's the same resolution
in all three axis.
And this is essentially what we're doing
with this microscope
because we have two cameras,
this one illuminates, this one image
and then they take turns.
You end up with two images
that you can then fuse
and the Z of this axis is
different from this one.
Again, I'm discussing this superficially
because I know Phil Keller will
discuss this in more detail.
We have this microscope working in my lab
and this is a slide that I put here
just to acknowledge two institutions,
the Marine Biological Laboratories
and the University of Puerto Rico
which were meeting places
where technologists like,
like microscopists like
people from Hari's group
and biologists from my group
were able to come together
and exchange ideas,
and I think these places are gonna be
increasingly more important
for interdisciplinary collaborations
necessary to address these problems.
What can we do with this?
So this is actually the brain
of the animal here in an embryo,
the tail, the head and that's the brain,
that ring that you see in there.
And I'm gonna play a movie
where we can actually see
the development of this
animal in real time.
I mean this is, as a
biologist this is spectacular
that we can see this.
You're gonna see the
animals, it starts to move,
it starts to twitch as the
nervous system comes online.
But even when it's twitching
you can get very crisp images.
Now, if you look at subsets of neurons
which we're going to do here
using subcellular markers
or markers that are more restricted
you can still see the,
you can see neurites,
specific neurites growing
into the brain of the animal,
this is all taken again in live animals.
And essentially you
can stop it at any time
and you can rotate it so
and with two-dimensional projections
because I'm using a screen
but these are three-dimensional data
since you can see resolution is very good
in all angles that you look at it.
And you can continue in movie.
So this gives us unprecedented access
to the events that are leading
to the formation of this nerve ring.
And then we had another collaboration
that was really enabling
which is that in C. Elegans
we know the lineage of every single cell,
we've known that since
the animal was developed
as a model organism,
that's how the original studies
of programmed cell death were done.
And this person, this is Zhirong Bao,
he's a scientist of Sloan Kettering
who's a computational biologist
and a developmental biologist.
And what I'm gonna be playing here
is an embryo that is in a four cell stage.
Now this is like playing a movie
that you know what's gonna happen
because we know the lineage.
We know for each one of these cells
we know who their progeny is gonna be
because those studies
have been done before.
But what he did is that
he trained a computer
to be able to recognize this in real time.
So as the animal is developing
the computer can keep track
of all of these nuclei
and it knows what each
cell is gonna become.
So why is this important to us?
It's important for two reasons.
One of them is because
when we're marking neurons
as we're gonna be doing here,
we can tell their identity
because if we have nuclei
that we're labeling in
the background in red
then we can keep the
identity of every single
one of these neurons that are emerging.
But the other aspect is that
we have an internal coordinate system.
As the neurons are growing out
and crossing the different nuclei
we know where each neuron is.
So if we take different embryos
and we're imaging different embryos
we can overlay them because we essentially
have a multi-point
internal coordinate system.
Does that make sense?
Okay, so what can we do with that
and here I'm gonna summarize
the work of a postdoc
in my lab, Mark Moyle,
this is five years of work
summarized in one slide.
So, essentially what we can,
what Mark did is he was
interested in identifying
the pioneering neurons
that lead to the formation,
that trail-blazed the formation
of the brain of the animal.
So he looked in embryos,
he labeled all membranes
and he found the first
membranes that are formed
that are part of the brain.
He traced them back to these cells here,
we're pseudo coloring
here so you can see them.
Then if he looked at the
nuclei he can actually identify
by name and last name
those specific cells.
Then he can image as I mentioned before
the development of the brain
so he can take these cells and kill them
and the hypothesis is if you kill them
because they're the first cells,
if the first cells are important
then you shouldn't be
able to develop a brain.
And we get these brainless animals
in which we cannot see,
essentially the brain is greatly abrogated
so these neurons are
actually very important.
And it turns out when we look back
in the maps that we have created
with the computational biologists
that this pioneer cells
are actually the cells
that are here in purple.
And they're like seamed cells,
they're cells that are holding together
the whole nerve ring.
And with that I'd like to essentially
bring to your attention
how we can both look at
how the brain is organized
and how the organization is
established during development.
And I'll finish by saying that
what we have been able to do
with this and our aspiration
is to create what would
be the first map of
metazoan neurodevelopment for any animal.
So we're systematically tracking
all of the incisions of these neurons
and creating this virtual
embryo that allows examination
of all of these decisions in the context
on the developing embryo which we think
will be enabling for neuroscience.
And with that I'll finish by
thanking the people that did the work.
This motley crew and you
for listening to me today.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So, I'm gonna be talking about
the complexity of the single cells
that make up the brain.
We've heard a lot about
neuronal populations
and how they're organized
which is quite amazing.
But if you go, if you zoom in
and look at any one of those cells
whether they're astrocytes or neurons
or microglia within the brain,
inside those cells is a plethora
of subcellular organelles
that are playing a huge role
in how the brain is operating.
I just want to draw your attention
to some of these organelles
who if they don't function properly
can lead to many of the
neurodegenerative diseases
that we're aware of.
So for instance mitochondria
that you can see here,
defects in mitochondria
lead to Parkinson's,
many of the Parkinson's disorders.
Lysosomes, proteins that
comprise some of these lysosomes
are responsible for
frontal temporal disorders.
And the endoplasmic
reticulum which you will hear
a lot about today is very much at play in
where mutations in proteins
that shape that organelle
underlies a variety of
spastic paraplegia disorders.
In order for us to really get
I think at this neurodegenerative
aspect of the brain
and how it ages and deteriorates,
we need to understand how these organelles
that comprise the cellular components
which is the unit of the
whole system of the brain
are organized.
So, this is a classic
transmission electron micrograph,
a 90 nanometer slice through a cell
to really reinforce the
complexity of these organelles.
What we wanna know is
more information about
the three-dimensional
organization of these organelles
and how proteins are
dynamically distributed.
That's one thing we wanna know
and I'm gonna be talking
about other layers
of information that we're
now beginning to get
in terms of the
organization of this system
thanks to high end microscopy technology.
So let's start with the
3D organelle shapes.
This is as I mentioned is a transmission
electron micrograph
slice of 90 nanometers.
What that means is within
that 90 nanometers slab
you have no Z information,
everything's flattened.
But thanks to technologies
like the Focused Ion Beam
Scanning milling system
that in combination with
scanning electron microscopy
we can now slice through the
cell at very thin sections,
four nanometer in this case.
And we've used that on
collaboration with Harald's
beautiful FIB-SEM system at Janelia
to begin slicing through parts of the cell
to reconstruct particular organelles,
in order to understand how these
organelles are shaped in 3D
and how they communicate
with other organelles.
What you're looking at
here is just the fine
complex architecture of
the endoplasmic reticulum
in a small, the edge of the cell.
In this panel right here
what you're looking at is
the confocal volume that we've sliced up
in what you would see
if you were using a confocal microscope.
So you can see there's a huge difference
between the reality of this organelle
as revealed by imaging at this very fine
three-dimensional architecture
versus the typical
image that you would get
if you are using conventional
confocal microscopes.
Now we've been working with Harald
to look in more detail
at these organelles.
In this case, we're looking at
plasma membrane, mitochondria
ER, endosomes that we can segment out
as you mill through these slices.
This is a two micron volume of the cell,
four nanometer voxels
and you can color code each
of these different organelles
to see how they're arranged
relative to each other.
Now the mitochondria that
you can see here in green
are intimately communicating with the ER
which is shown in red and
there's a lot of crosstalk
between these two organelles
that's absolutely critical for
calcium handling in the cell
for reactive oxygen exchange,
as well as lipid and other
types of communication.
Well, how do we localize
proteins on these organelles?
And the approach that we've been taking
really builds from really
the 20 years or more
of work that people have done
using fluorescent protein technology,
which allows you to tag
proteins of interest
and then look at how they're distributed.
Now in order for us to get high resolution
protein as well as lipid distribution
to understand the fine architecture
in a three-dimensional section of a cell,
we've applied Lattice
Light Sheet Microscopy
developed by Eric Betzig and colleagues,
where essentially you take
ultra thin vessel beams
to create a thin 2D optical lattice
which is then used as
a sheet to pass through
your cell of interest.
What this allows is ultra
thin slicing through a cell
which is at a much smaller scale
than big neuronal slices, sections.
And because we have
such a thin light sheet
that's basically almost the same dimension
as the X, Y lateral resolution
that you get with the microscope,
you have isotropic resolution.
And again it's low, it's
relatively low to photo toxicity
because it's a lattice sheet of light
rather than a full sheet.
So we combined the lattice
light sheet microscope
with a point localization
or PALM-like imaging
where individual molecules,
in this case we're
looking at lipid molecules
that bind and then
dissociate from membranes.
And whenever they're
bound they create a spot
on the surface of that membrane
that we can fit with very high accuracy
by point PSF centroid fitting.
And when we do that we can reconstruct
the entire sort of organelle distribution,
map it out in 3D through
lattice light sheet imaging
with a combination of plotting out
all the individual
distributions of these lipids
that have been using super
resolution imaging docked in
and put in place.
Now, now that we have an
image of all these organelles
in this you can see mitochondria here
and this web-like structure represents
the endoplasmic reticulum,
we can now come in and dock in
particular proteins of interest.
I'm just gonna zoom in on this area here
because what we're
particularly interested in
or we're interested in in this study
was how proteins that are part
of the endoplasmic reticulum
which is this large structure that expands
throughout the cytoplasm,
it's this tubular meshwork,
how its organized.
And so what we can do
with this technology is
superimpose our distributions
of fluorescent proteins
that we've specifically
genetically engineered and tagged
onto our fluorescently acquired image
using this lattice light sheet system
to dock in where these
proteins are localized.
And this is an example where we have
again, all of the membranes of the cell
that have been painted out if you will
using the lipid, our lipid probe
and single molecule
super resolution imaging.
And we're now correlating it
with the diffraction
limited image of Sec61 beta
tagged with an mEmerald
of fluorescent probe.
And you can see how they align.
This is exciting to us because
it really sets the stage
for beginning to investigate
a whole slew of different
proteins and how they localize
within this cellular system.
So we think that fits in and
Lattice Light Sheet-PAINT
or PALM-like correlative approaches
will allow us to really
gain deeper information
about how all of these
organelles are shaped
in three dimensions,
and how different proteins
might distribute on them.
But one of the challenges
that we still face
is how many organelles are arranged
relative to each other
in a living cell context.
In particular that's
important for understanding
how different organelles
are contacting each other
and communicating with each other.
We know for instance the
endoplasmic reticulum
which is this sort of snake-like structure
that you can see in this EM image
is contacting virtually
every other organelle
within the cell
and communicating with those organelles
through lipid trafficking, ROS,
essentially exchange of
reactive oxygen species,
calcium signaling.
Many other types of
communication is going on
between these organelles.
And our problem with
trying to understand that
is that we haven't been
able to look simultaneously
at all of these organelles
in a living cell context.
We can see them clearly
with electron microscopy
but if we do fluorescent
time lapse imaging
we're limited to imaging two or three
of these organelles at one time
because of this problem of
overlap in emission spectrum
in among the different
fluorescent proteins
that are available.
So here we have classic
fluorescent proteins
that have different emission spectrum,
CFP, GFP, YFP.
These are the emission
spectrum for each of these
different fluorescent probes.
And the problem is their
emission spectrum is overlapping.
And what that means is that if you tagged
a particular organelle with
different fluorescent probes
like the ones that I just mentioned
which are the most widely
used fluorescent probes,
and then you image essentially,
you go across the emission spectrum
to look at any particular
wavelength of light
which population of
organelle you've looked at,
you can see that you have overlap
at any particular wavelength.
So that means if you were
imaging for instance at 438
you'd see three different,
you would not be able to
distinguish mitochondria,
ER and lysosomes from each other.
It would just be one big blur.
And hence you could not distinguish
how these different
organelles are behaving
relative to each other.
So to overcome that challenge,
two postdocs in the lab
decided to employ a technology
called Multispectral
Imaging to try to unravel
this overlapping emission spectrum.
And a strategy that they
used was essentially take,
if you know the the emission spectra
of each of these different fluorophores
you can then query an
observed pixel spectrum
that's a combination of one
or more of these fluorophores,
and then use linear unmixing
to decipher what combination of
and in what abundance any one
or two or more of these fluorophores
would give rise to this
particular spectrum.
And using that we can at
each pixel of our image
unmix to determine which
fluorophore is giving rise
to the signal that we're
observing at that pixel.
And so we combine that with
Lattice Light Sheet Microscopy
to be able to image simultaneously
six different organelles
within the cell over time.
In order to do that we've
essentially introduced
six different laser lines that
cover the visible spectrum
that allows us to excite the fluorophore
that we've tagged on each one
of these different organelles.
And then we do our linear
unmixing algorithms to determine
each of the specific spectra
associated with each organelle.
And this is what you can see in the case
of these six different
organelles that we've
introduced fluorescent tags for.
Now this is in a single cell
so we can superimpose all of these signals
on top of each other to simultaneously
see in a three-dimensional space
because we're using
that lattice light sheet
to move through the
whole volume of the cell,
how all of these
organelles are distributed.
Now with this technique,
we can begin to zone in on
really specific measurements in terms of
organelle distribution, localization,
essentially connectivity.
This is just a set of values for
the number of organelles
that each of these
different populations
of organelles represent.
So for instance on average in
the cell that we're looking at
there's about 89
lysosomes, 186 peroxisomes,
157 lipid droplets.
The ER occupies by far the
largest volume in this cell
among all of these different organelles.
It's about 30 times the
size of the Golgi apparatus
which is involved in
the secretory pathway,
eight to nine times the
size of the mitochondria
which is involved in energy
production within the cell.
Now we can also come in and segment
these individual organelles to look at how
they are connected to each other,
how they're contacting each other
in order to begin to
understand the communication,
the cross communication
or crosstalk in activity
that we know is so important for how
cells are operating and communicating
with other cells in their environment.
For instance the endoplasmic reticulum
controls the secretory pathway
together with the Golgi apparatus.
It's what's secreting
the paraneural network
that we heard earlier about.
It's critical for us to really understand
how these organelles behave
relative to each other
and from these types of segmented images,
we can create what we've
been able to describe
what we call the organelle interactome.
Where we just measure
the pairwise contacts
between these different organelles
in our images of these cells.
And from that we can see the
frequency of communication
that different organelles
have with each other.
You can see here that the ER is by far
the most communicative
of all of the organelles,
it's contacting everyone.
Importantly if you look
at a single cell over time
you can see that this
organelle interactome
is conserved over fairly
significant periods of time,
and that is despite the fact
that any particular contact that we see
is relatively transient.
I should emphasize that this interactome
changes dramatically if we
perturb the cell in different ways,
we can depolymerize microtubules
or starve cells in different ways,
and we dramatically change
the way these organelles
are interacting with each other.
Now this is a movie
where we've segmented out
the mitochondria as an
example of an organelle
that is intimately communicating
with the endoplasmic reticulum.
On the right hand side
represents the surface,
all of the surface sites of mitochondria
where we see ER signal.
So the ER is wrapping around
the surface of the mitochondria
and intimately
communicating with virtually
all of those mitochondrial
elements that we see in the cell.
This contact we think is what's up,
we think there's calcium flux
between the ER and mitochondria.
That calcium is playing an important role
for mitochondrial output, how much energy
is being produced by the mitochondria.
We also know there's lipid and
cholesterol being transferred
across these contact sites,
and importantly reactive oxygens, ROS,
reactive oxygen species
is being trafficked
across those contacts
which could play a big role in the
disulfide bond formation
and protein remodeling
occurring in the endoplasmic reticulum.
Now let's focus in on the ER for a second.
It occupies 25% of the cell cytoplasm.
We can measure that using
our lattice light sheet
three-dimensional reconstruction.
What is interesting is that if we look at,
we plot out the position of the ER
over a 15-minute time period
which you can see in this movie,
what we find is that the
ER has pretty much explored
the entire cytoplasm over just 15 minutes.
So it is a very dynamic organelle
that has lots of capability
of communicating.
Now in my final two minutes or one minute
I wanna take you through how
fast these organelles can move.
We know that the ER has the capability
of exploring that cytoplasm.
Let's look at its dynamics
at higher resolution.
We can do this using a TIRF-SIM system.
We can see these tubule
matrices move incredibly fast.
Interestingly the tubes themselves
undergo an oscillatory activity,
that's ATP and GTP-dependent
so it's not just thermally driven.
And finally we can actually come in
and start mapping out individual proteins
that move or diffuse along the surface
of the endoplasmic reticulum.
That's what you're seeing here.
Each of these yellow spots
represent a halo tagged protein
that is associated with
the membrane of the ER
and we can begin to map out
the trajectories of these proteins,
and that's shown here for another ER
resident protein Sec61 beta.
If you sum up all of these trajectories
you see that these proteins
and this is a transmembrane
protein you're looking at,
will explore the whole
surface of that ER freely.
Now in my final movie here,
I just wanna show here's an example where
we're mapping out a protein
that actually interacts,
it's on the surface of the ER
but it is part of a tethering complex
that brings the ER close
to the mitochondria.
And what we can see is when we track
these individual molecules
as they diffuse across
the surface of the ER,
we can see that as they move
across the area of the ER
that's in close proximity of mitochondria,
they slow down significantly.
Consistent with a transient interaction
of this tethering protein
with the target protein on mitochondria.
So with that I wanna end and say that
this field is really being
significantly impacted
by the high resolution
technology that's now available
that scans from electron microscopy
up to the fast imaging technology.
People in my lab have
been greatly impacted by
the physicists at Janelia,
Eric Betzig and Harald in particular
who've really provided the technology
that allow us to do this type of work.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So as you know, life sciences are always
trying to make best use of light for many
different purposes.
For instance we use x-ray
beam for crystallography
and the infrared light for
vibrational spectroscopy.
But most biologists use visible light.
And chromophore is a structure unit
so that can absorb certain visible light,
and it is responsible for color
and in many cases it has
the pi-conjugation system.
And single and double
bonds appear alternately
so that the Pi electrons
can be delocalized.
So electrons oscillate or
sing on the chromophore
and that's quite important
for the interaction
with the visible light.
And my laboratory is engaged in
technological innovation in bio-imaging
and principally using
fluorescent proteins.
And I'd like to introduce to you,
so the most classical
the fluorescent protein
Aequorea GFP.
And long time ago, so in 1962
Osamu Shimomura discovered protein
and from the light-emitting
organ of the jelly fish.
And just 30 years later in '92 it's seen
then it was cloned by Doug Prasher.
And in '94, so the heterologous
expression with Aequorea GFP
was achieved by Martin
Chalfie at Columbia, okay.
And then this is the primary
structure of Aequorea GFP,
just 238 amino acid.
So there's no chromophore
that I defined a moment ago
in the peptide.
But from this three amino acid
there's serine, tyrosine, glycine
so three reactions occur
spontaneously, okay.
And cyclization, dehydration
and oxidation reactions
to make the Pi-conjugation system.
So this is the GFP's chromophore
and which observes blue light, okay?
But this light doesn't say
anything about its fluorescence.
This is a crystal
structure they call a GFP
and the beta-barrel structure.
And the 11 stranded beta-barrel
with one alpha helix inside,
and the chromophore is
formed on the helix,
and that the barrel is very robust.
And the chromophore is packed inside
and it takes very rigid structure
so that explains why GFP's fluorescence
quantum yield is very high.
And the mutagen studies get
done by Dr. Roger Tsien,
so produced quite a few color variance
and the the more useful and brighter.
And I stayed in Roger's
lab from '95 to '98
and I used CFP and the YFP
and as the donor and acceptor
for FRET so to create.
So the genetically encoded
indicator for calcium ion,
Cameleons as Mark mentioned kindly.
So now I'd like to discuss
why calcium imaging
is so interesting and appealing.
So there should be two major reasons.
First, calcium signaling
is very, so dynamic.
The concentration of free calcium ion
it changes so greatly so it should be fun.
To observe for instance
here calcium oscillations.
The second, so due to the endogenous
and the very abundant
calcium buffering systems
we can express a huge
amount of calcium probes
so without affecting intracellular calcium
dynamics very much, okay?
We can increase the signals,
signal-to-noise ratio.
Here we expressed a large
quantity of Cameleon
in excitatory neurons
with the forebrain mouse.
And we signed the skinless
head with excitation light
and to get these calcium readout.
And through this intact
skull and the video rate
for more than 30 minutes.
So this readout reflect
spontaneous neuronal activities
and which are composed
of multiple oscillations
of different frequencies
and very symmetrical.
And the mouse was half awake
so when we gave visual stimulation
so we saw an evoked response in the path,
in the visual cortex.
Now back to, so this slide.
GFP is chromophore
and it has a phenol ring.
So it comes from tyrosine residue, okay?
Well, almost all of the
fluorescent proteins now available
so do have phenol rings in
there chromophores, okay?
And the exceptions, the CFP and the BFP,
so they have indole ring or imidazole ring
coming from tryptophan and the histidine.
But phenol ring containing
chromophore is most common.
And that there is an equilibrium
between protonated and ionized state
of the phenol hydroxyl group.
And that they then absorb
400 and 480 nanometer light.
And in many cases, so the
ionized form fluorescent, okay.
Therefore, GFP basically has
bimodal absorption spectrum.
And now a circular permutation.
And a long time ago just serendipitously
Geoff Baird and in Roger's lab found,
so this site 144, 145,
so the midpoint of the beta
strand number seven (mumbles),
so circular permutation.
So circular permuted GFP can synthesize
chromophore very well,
and now so the chromophore.
The equilibrium is quite
sensitive to a neighboring event
such as a calcium-dependent
protein-protein interaction.
So this is the operational
principle of GCaMP or pericam.
The very important point is that
so that here calcium-binding
changes absorption spectrum
not fluorescence quantum yield, okay.
As a kind of, a future perspective,
so the GCaMP should be well combined
with photo-acoustic imaging.
Now I have to say and
not only the jellyfish
but some of them are done
in animals or marine animals
so can produce quite similar
fluorescent proteins, okay?
And while we have cloned
many new fluorescent proteins
from those animals.
By using this, so these
green red proteins,
we some time ago we
developed cell cycle probe.
And we used the Ubiquitin Oscillator.
Cell cycle-dependent proteolysis,
so to create the cell cycle probe
which labels individual
nuclei in genome phase red
and those in S, G2, M phases green.
That's FUCCI and the
green and red indicate,
so the go and stop.
That S phase entry, so
like a traffic signal
and when the FUCCI was
introduced into HeLa cells,
so derived from malignant tumor
we observed a cell cycle operation
in the other time at a single cell level.
But when we did the same thing using
benign tumor derived cell line
we saw very clear contact inhibition.
And upon reaching convertible urea
all of the cells became red
and then stopped so their proliferation.
And we introduced scratch
and so some of the cells
or that one in green
after some rate and time,
so they reenter the cell
cycle and to build a gap.
And we prepared FUCCI transgenic mice,
so this is a coronal section of an embryo
and in the brain, so neural stem cells
at the green nuclei line
in the ventricular zone
but post-mortem neurons
had only red nuclei
in the cortical (mumbles).
And the green and the red
signify cell proliferation
and the differentiation.
And during the embryogenesis with time,
so green to red ratio decreased,
so the earlier the more proliferation,
the later the more differentiation.
And after the burst so the
red signal became predominant
but even in adult tissue
so we can identify
very few green nuclei
and the cells with the green nuclei
corresponded to tissue stem
cells like a neural stem cells
found in the dentate gyrus, okay.
And when we used zebrafish
embryo very transparently
so we can obtain cell cycle
profile in four dimensions.
So this is a segmentation period of embryo
and a side view on head and tail,
and again with time green
to red ratio decreased
but some other organs
like retina and the brain,
so very green.
And in top view in addition to two eyes,
so we saw a notochord.
So differentiating notochord
and in notochord we discovered,
so the cell cycle transitions
and moved, traveled
from head to tail like this.
So this G1, this transition
moved towards here.
And we think, so the cell cycle regulation
in the notochord is
linked to somite genesis
which is also characterized
by head to tail
progression of differentiation.
But anyhow, it's quite very amazing
that we can visualize that
the middle of the body
from outside so that's just because,
so the fish embryo's a bit transparent.
And by contrast, mouse embryos,
well, mammary animals where
including us are turbid.
Yes, visible light
scatters very much inside
so our body so like now mentioned, okay?
Now, tissue clear identification
and long time ago we discover that
the membrane for Western Blotting analysis
it became transparent when
soaked in 4 molar urea.
And we knew that, so the GFP beta-barrel,
it's a brave and tough, so rigid
and tolerant of high
concentration of urea.
We started, so the clearing
and devolution 2011,
so with our paper on ScaleA2
which is the first and urea-based
aqueous solution for tissue
clear identification.
And then it was followed by many explosion
of many new techniques,
and also two years ago we
reported some modification
ScaleS, ScaleS that contains
sorbitol in addition to urea
and we verify that ScaleS can preserve
the fluorescent signal
and also outer structures,
so subset of outer
structures like a synapse.
I think researchers should be aware
of the critical trade-off
between effective clearing
and the tissue signal preservation.
And also we invented AbScale method
so which enables three-dimensional
immunohistochemistry.
And some time ago the Saito group at BSI
generated a single APP
knock-in mouse models
of Alzheimer disease.
And we applied AbScale method,
so to the brain of aged APP knock-in mice.
And to visualize A beta-plaques we used
Alexa488 labeled and antibody.
And there was a brain got
prepared from a nine-month old
and APP knock-in mouse and very sparse.
But in 18-month old, so we saw,
we observed so many
immuno-labeled A beta-plaques
and yes, even the experiment,
we transcardially perfused
the entire vasculature
with Texas Red-lectin
to label blood vessels
with red fluorescence
and then we immune-stained
the A beta-plaques with green
and to obtain this, so the 3D perspective.
Very comprehensive perspective of how
A beta-plaques interferes
with blood vessels.
Then we took interest
in a special association
of A beta-plaques with microglial cells.
And we applied so the dual color AbScale
so to a brain slice prepared
from APP knock-in mouse.
And we analyzed the interaction
between these two object
by light sheet microscopy observation.
And we measured the distance
from each microglia center
to the nearest plaque age in the 3D space.
Those measurements should
provide the information about
stability of plaque
neuritis, inflammatory state.
For instance, so two neighboring
plaques with similar size
but different association
with microglial cells,
very direct to contact
versus very isolated.
We think they suggest acute
neuritic state versus obsolete.
And in a similar way we 3D imaged plaque
microglia association in
post-mortem brain samples
of AD patient of more than 50 years old.
And in these three brain
samples we observed,
detected very clear cored
plaques, green ones.
And the cored plaques without
and with microglia association.
But in the remaining
six of the brain samples
we didn't see any cored plaques.
So then we became interested
in diffused plaques.
So diffused plaques are
basically undetectable,
not detectable in the
two-dimensional image.
But our new software can re-slice,
so the 3D reconstruction systemically
and with different sizes,
different thickness, okay?
And that helped us to identify
diffused plaques of different sizes.
And the diffused plaques are usually
assumed to be very
primitive and very isolated
from any inflammatory cells,
but we found, so most of
them can show the sign of
neuritis with considerable
association with microglial cells.
Clinically, diffused plaques are ambiguous
but they're potentially
very, very important, okay?
And Scale plus FUCCI we
studied vascular niche
for neural stem cells
in in the dentate gyrus.
And that we were able...
So neural stem cells or
proliferative neural stem cells
we used FUCCI S, G2, M phase marker
and the blood vessels
were labeled with red.
And the green nuclei,
so the neural stem cells
were indeed localized
inside the dentate gyrus
not outside of it.
And we again performed
distance measurement
in a three-dimensional space.
We measured distance
from each green nucleus,
so to the nearest blood vessel, okay?
And then we came to a conclusion,
so the neural stem cells are more closely
associated with blood
vessels than matured neurons.
And Rusty has been saying about
hippocampal neurogenesis is operated by
exposure to enriched environment
and we performed the
comparative experiment,
comparative experiment and
large-scale 3D reconstruction.
And our data showed the
enriched environment increased
so the number or density
of neural stem cells
but did not change so their
association with blood vessels.
This a comprehensive data I think, I hope.
All right, so this slide is an interplay
between light and life.
Well I remember that Roger Tsien,
Roger used to remind us
nature is very kind to us,
to researchers
and that nature still
remains the best source
of bio-imaging tools, okay?
And this is my last slide
and only a scientist
with a respect for nature
would have been permitted to surpass it
in English, Japanese and Chinese.
And thank you very much for attention.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo music)